[Applause]
all right yesterday Joe Biden traveled
to Minnesota to give a speech tting of
all things bomic how's that working out
for you take a look folks bomic is just
another way of saying the American
dream let me be clear bomic is not the
American dream it is a national
nightmare marked by out of control
inflation everyday Necessities are now
unaffordable for millions of hardworking
Americans almost 2third of the American
people are living paycheck to paycheck
so what about the what about this
embodies the American dream President
Biden can you tell us because by the way
it's not just affecting everyday
Americans a Biden back wind power
company actually canceled their project
despite receiving a billion dollars in
your taxpayer funded subsidies citing
the burden of biomics oh can anyone say
cylindra now meanwhile Auto Company
executives are finally coming clean the
electric vehicles that the government is
mandating it's not working for their
business the public doesn't want them
here with reaction Fox News contributor
Lisa Booth co-host of the big money show
on Fox Business Brian
brenberg wow that says a lot well I mean
if he thinks this is a dream what will
the nightmare look like if we have four
more years Joe Biden I mean my god look
I I think a lot of these climate
policies it's about two things one it's
about re-engineering the economy and
using these climate policies as a
vehicle I remember when aoc's former uh
Chief of Staff said that the green New
Deal was actually about overhauling the
economy and then I think the second
thing is they don't want us to own
anything I mean the world economic Forum
said as much and if you look at electric
vehicles you even have the Washington
Post warning that the electrical grd is
not prepare not prepared for this
massive push to of her grand home oh
yeah yeah she yeah ask her how that
worked out right you know and then we
don't have raw materials as well it's
incredibly expensive so what does that
mean for car ownership for Americans
right and then you look at States like
California during a heat wve where
they're like oh actually you're not
allowed to go charge your car but yet we
want to have this massive poal electric
vehicles it's insane in California that
you could only charge your car between
these certain hours yeah like but they
want to control us and that gives them
the opportunity to do so true that's a
good point yeah and companies are
walking away from this I mean like the
big auto companies said we're all in on
the EVS last year what are they saying
this year oh we're giving up now because
we can't make any money GM says we're
out of a partnership with Honda Ford
says we're not making the trucks anymore
even Tesla the one people actually want
to buy Elon Musk is saying I don't think
the demand for these things is as high
as it used to be so when companies get
it and taxpayers start to get it maybe
we get away from the subsidies that are
bankrupting us with all this green
spending by the way you you have to
literally pillage Mother Earth to get
the manganese and the Cobalt and the
nickel using big heavy equipment that
uses Diesel and on top of the fact what
90% of our power grid isn't that fossil
fuel related that charges the battery
exactly and you know where they're
getting a lot of these materials now
they want to farm the ocean floor mine
the ocean floor guess who controls
almost all of that China and they're
going after it aggressively and nobody
wants to get in the way of it so you
think about how vulnerable we are we
don't want these products we're forced
to get them and we got to buy them from
the guys funding Iran and Hamas how does
that make sense and and for what I
remember when Senator Kennedy asked a
Biden en energy official he said okay
let's say we spend $50 trillion how much
is that going to reduce temperatures
around the world and he couldn't answer
right and and so so what is the point of
all this right they told us before in
the 1970s it was going to be the Ice Age
then it's warming I think I'll stick to
my air condition
living in Florida and live a normal life
I mean really it's crazy is there any
more of our appliances our gas stoves
our air conditioners our refrigerators
how about you just leave us the hell
alone leave us alone leave us alone
leave us alone all right and by the way
the people that want to buy a Tesla or
an electric car I'm fine let them Ford
lost 4.5 billion I think it's bad
business yeah but don't force people to
do it which is what and then also if so
good why do you have to coers people
into it great point that makes too
mucho all right thank you both hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else